hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to well I
think since this last weekend we all
know what the big blockbuster to beat
this year is that's right scary movie 5
the 5th and the record-breaking saga
that seems to bring in less and less
money every single time one's released
wait a minute how can that be when other
spoof movies have been doing so well
like haunted house and vampires suck and
stay in Hell sing and bike out what the
hell happened what the hell happened it
gets both movies some of our best jokes
at tires and even characters used to go
into them even legendary comedian no
broads made some of his biggest hits
with spoof movies but now it seems like
every time someone even hears the word
spoof satire or parody the first thing
that pops into their heads aren't
classics like airplane or space balls
it's films that have almost become bad
words like epic movie or meet the spark
needs which is why I have to ask the
painfully sad question is parody dead it
certainly seems that way I'm noticing
more and more that when people even see
parodies attempted there's this big
resistance to them like they're afraid
all the Sanders is going to do is just
make references to other things and not
actually do anything comedic with it
just make the reference so like guess
the best way to understand faults and
parodies nowadays is to take a good
close look at what exactly they're doing
wrong what makes films like Hot Shots or
Robin Hood Men in Tights work and a film
like disaster movie or dance flick not
there has certainly been sad tires of
film in the past dating all the way back
to Chaplin days if not further but the
first movie specifically decides one
film throughout most of it and created
the spoof formula we're almost familiar
with is Mel Brooks's Young Frankenstein
that's frank enstein the company came
from the idea of taking something that
was so massive so scary and so dramatic
but instead of looking at it from a
different point of view that asked what
if the little mistakes and funny flaws
of humanity were much more prominent in
the story what if the blind man made a
few accidents during his scene what if
Igor was in such denial he didn't even
know that he had a
these are ideas that all stem from the
original source material but instead
gave them a comedic edge other
filmmakers would take their shot at
doing feature-length booths as well
those sucker brothers and Jim Abrams
were following suit satirizing airport
with airplane top gun with hotshots
Rambo and hotshots part dune and so
forth all these movies were big hits and
it seemed like parodies were only coming
out bigger funnier and faster but maybe
they were starting to come out too fast
when the movie spy hard came out less
qualified filmmakers suddenly realized
how easy it is to make a parody look
funny even if the humor was lacking
let's see here's some slabs dig a few
puns
didn't look like Swiss cheese when they
find you that's no Gouda scenes in this
movie they look like other scenes from
movies and of course a touch of girls
out humour they also seem to be an
emphasis on shoving as many movie
parodies as possible not because they
had anything clever to say about it or
do with the material but because hey if
hot shots just satirize one movie
imagine what a flick satirizing tons of
movies can do well I'll tell you exactly
what I can do it could be a piece of
shit becoming too crowded and too
unfocused and you put less time into
creating good jokes and characters and
it stitch had to make more time cramming
it as main movie references as you can
but the advertising seemed to work
people went to this movie because they
thought it was done by the people who
did hot shots and make a gun but when
they got in they were sadly disappointed
but who cares this was new Hollywood
once they had your ticket that opening
weekend nothing else mattered that's the
way things are done now so they didn't
need a movie to actually be funny they
just needed it to look funny because of
this incredibly low gray Perry's were
made as fast as possible and as cheap as
possible hopefully fooling you into
thinking you were seeing material from
the great spoof masters and to make
things worse even the great spoof
masters we're starting to lose their
touch the suckers Abram team split up
and they all went on their separate ways
to do their own parodies and all of them
were slow lame and pretty weak even
though Brooke seem to be slowing down
with a really awkward satire of the
Dracula movies and yeah
none of these were doing Leslie
Gilson a favors either so for a while
the movie parody seemed to slowly be
dying with nobody trying to do anything
new or inventive that is until Keenan
Ivory Wayans came along to direct scary
movie a very specific kind of satire as
it did just make fun of scary films as a
genre it made fun of scary films of only
the past few years so it didn't wait to
see if these movies would withstand the
passage of time and therefore be worth
satirizing the instead took the
zeitgeist route and mocked whatever was
popular at the time what are you waiting
for huh what are you mad by yeah how
many people under 25 even remember what
that satirizing it also was shall we say
a bit more obvious with its humor if
there's a character they thought was
dumb from another movie they make him a
retard in this version and it didn't
hint that a movie character was going to
make the wrong move they literally put a
sign saying that they made the wrong
move and the grosso humor wasn't just
over the top it was off the fucking fork
god that's disgusting
and it was a monster hit suddenly flicks
like airplane and space balls weren't
the film's to mimic anymore
it was scary movie and the irony was
that the film everyone thought would
save parody flicks actually made the
situation worse
that's right hastily rushed knock off
after hastily rushed knock off soon
followed and a scary movie - dobby is
humour well logically there's what have
to be more obvious to be even more
outrageous so much so that even scary
movie hastily shoved out a lame ass
knock off with its own sequel and just
like everyone was doing it was even more
obvious and more gross thus this gave
birth to the new norm of god-awful
entertainment usually referred to as the
movie movie the film series that focused
on satirizing not a film series or even
really a genre film but just whatever is
popular at the time more concerned about
getting the movie out fast then getting
it out smart or good films like epic
movie disaster movie date movie
all trying to simulate the scary-movie
formula mixing what's popular with
what's totally disgusting there were
rumors that the makers of these films
didn't even see the films that they were
mocking they just saw early production
pictures from the set and shouted make
it look like that and you know what I
really wouldn't be shocked if that was
the truth the need for their movie to
put in references to other movies got so
bad that they didn't even need to have
anything in common with it I shit you
not meet the Spartans combines 300 and
meet the parents what the fuck do those
two things have in common again the site
guys must know now there's nothing wrong
with cashing in on the site guys every
once in a while but when you make it
your main focus and try to work it into
every single solitary thing you create
you get now granted none of these movies
were as big a hit as scary movie or the
hotshot films but obviously there must
be an audience for them if they keep
getting made so why are there still
people continuing to be duped well you
know the phrase of suckers born every
minute there's a lot of truth to that
there's always somebody who's going to
come across a spoof film for the first
time and like the idea that's something
that they enjoyed is being satirized so
the more references to other films a
parody can fit in the more likely you
are to connect with something you
recognize and therefore will possibly go
see it and the spoof movies now are so
easy and so fast to make because of that
reason that there's no point to try and
make a film that's funny or even a big
hit all it has to do is make enough to
be a profit and as long as there's
dumbasses out there saying oh I
recognize that they're going to make fun
of something I like and do it in a
clever way they will always be putting
no effort into it
what spoof films nowadays are missing is
that the humor doesn't come from just
turning something popular into something
silly or blindly making references it
comes from a very focused and smart
analysis of why we like what we like and
ultimately making fun of it the jokes in
Young Frankenstein work because it tries
hard to create the environment and
atmosphere the original Frankenstein
created
that way seems like the blind man work
because you recognize and feel the
weight of the original and the contrast
of putting something as silly as
lighting his finger on fire is now
hilarious because it makes you realize
how funny you would be if that did
happen in the original on top of that I
would argue that many of them created
funny characters Spaceballs doesn't work
because it's just acknowledging Star
Wars existed it works because an
intimidating strategist is now replaced
with a pathetic dweeb in the same role
James Earl Jones being switched out with
Rick Moranis both given the same amount
of power and supposedly fear is what
makes so much of this film so funny as
well as the other timeless characters
that this satire created even though
Warner Brothers cartoons figure this out
in what's opera doc the way the genius
of vogner's music is still there but
it's made funny when the main characters
are replaced with Bugs Bunny and Elmer
Fudd it's the contrast of character and
situation that makes it humorous not
acknowledging something that's popular
is still popular Weird Al Yankovic has
made a living inserting himself into
some iconic roles and the closer he can
mimic the size and scope of what you
enjoy so much the funnier he can make it
when he reduces something so serious to
something so not serious like food
good parity comes from a true
understanding of what your satirizing
capturing its strengths while playfully
acknowledging its flaws and you can't do
that if your concern is squeezing in
reference after reference because you
don't have time to let the environment
or the characters you create and/or mock
sink in so with such an emphasis on
getting people in theater seats and
nothing else is parody truly dead not
necessarily
it may be dead in theaters for the time
but it is still alive and well
online comedic groups like college humor
how it should have ended animation
domination high-def Funny or Die these
are all great satyrs who know how to
quickly establish the tone of what their
satirizing make clever jokes about it
and keep it focused in just a few
minutes they set up the environment and
characters so that they instantly are
recognizable and know what elements to
move around or switch out in order for
it to be funny on top of that there's
also good satire on TV
Comedy Central still brings us their
fake news with The Daily Show and
Stephen Colbert and of course South Park
always knows the best way to mock
everything whether it be movies or
anything else in media and how about the
onion they're still funny as hell and
going strong then papers online and a
video for so well it does look like good
parody and movies is down and out for a
while
I don't think parody will ever truly die
it just takes on different shapes and
different art forms now while I do miss
looking forward to cinematic greats like
airplane or space balls there's still
new sad tires being made and many of
them are just as funny because for every
person who just wants to use comedy as a
means to make a quick buck
there's hundreds more out there who know
good humor and more importantly how to
display it and for those who still think
something like epic movie is along the
same lines as Young Frankenstein you
will always be a prime example of
someone who will never get the joke on a
Nostalgia Critic I remember it so you
don't have to
you